hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar diagnosis and management of
viral infections and the transplant
population i am michelle ashton of
labyrinth and i'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab route the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration it's
presented by abbott molecular to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.cannainsider.com/careers green label
to ask a question and click on the send
button questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the arrows at the top
right hand corner of the presentation
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problems by typing it into the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
widow and follow the process to obtain
your credits
I now present today's speaker dr. matt
vinegar the director of clinical biology
and a professor of laboratory medicine
and pathology at mayo clinic to learn
more about our speaker it pleases a
speaker tab at the top of the
presentation window dr. vinegar will now
begin his presentation
thanks for joining me for this webinar
presentation on the diagnosis and
management of viral infections in the
transplant population I think this is an
important topic for both laboratory
professionals and healthcare providers
who are caring for transplant patients
as these infections are important causes
of morbidity and mortality in this
patient population before we begin I
want to quickly review the relevant
financial disclosures for this
presentation first support for this
program is being provided by Abbott and
I am presenting at the request of Abbott
I'm also an advisory board member for
DIA sauron molecular and I recently
served as a member of an advisory board
for Roche Diagnostics I won't be
discussing any off-label usage of
laboratory diagnostic tests or
antimicrobials so with that let's get
started over the course of this
presentation we're gonna focus our
discussion on four key objectives with
the first being to define the potential
clinical manifestations of sada megalo
virus epstein-barr virus and BK virus in
the transplant population second we'll
review the available laboratory methods
that are used in the diagnosis and
management of these viral infections
among transplant recipients third we'll
discuss the advantages and limitations
of various diagnostic assays and I'll
highlight key considerations for their
appropriate use and interpretation and
then finally I'll hope to introduce some
new tests that may allow healthcare
providers to predict a patient's
response to certain antiviral
medications
I think it's important that we first set
the stage by defining the overall
magnitude of transplantation in the
United States and how this will likely
continue to be an issue of increasing
importance in the years to come as you
can see on the figure on this slide the
number of transplants performed in the
United States has increased steadily and
significantly over the past 20 years
from just over a 15,000 performed in
1991 to over 35,000 transplant
procedures being performed in 2018 this
is important because this population of
patients is generally at higher risk for
developing a range of infections in the
post transplant period and because of
this we need to have a sophisticated set
of laboratory tools at our disposal so
that we can accurately and timely
provide diagnosis and effective
management of these patients I think
this is especially true when it comes to
viral infections among transplant
recipients in whom it truly becomes a
delicate balancing act for the
transplant team to maintain the
viability and function of the
transplanted allograft while at the same
time reducing the risk of infection for
that particular patient now this is
because immunosuppressive medications
that are used following transplantation
to reduce the risk of rejection of that
transplanted allograft those medications
also increase the risk of infection so
if the team airs on the side of too
little immunosuppression in order to
reduce the risk
infection that may actually tip the
scale and increase the risk that the
recipients immune system will reject the
transplanted allograft but conversely if
too much amino suppression is given that
will increase the risk of infection
which will not only put the patient at
risk but also the transplanted organ so
what are the important causes of viral
infection among transplant recipients
well there are a number of viruses that
can cause significant morbidity and
mortality in this patient population
including members of the herpes Verde
such as cytomegalovirus epstein-barr
virus herpes simplex virus types one and
two varicella-zoster virus and human
herpes virus type 6 but in addition to
the herpes viruses there are others such
as BK virus the hepatitis viruses and
then a whole range of respiratory
viruses which can cause significant
disease among our transplant patients
however in this presentation we're gonna
focus our discussion on three of these
viruses namely sada megalo virus or CMV
epstein-barr virus which I'll refer to
as EBV and BK virus and we're going to
accomplish this by reviewing three case
vignettes and throughout these cases
I'll highlight the potential clinical
manifestations of these viral infections
and the laboratory methods that we can
use to diagnose and manage these
infections so our first case is that of
a 58 year old patient who's nine months
status post lung transplant due to
chronic obstructive pulmonary disease or
COPD and prior to this patients
transplantation serologic testing
for Sodom aglow virus was performed and
the results showed that the donor was
serial positive and the recipient was
zero negative so that would be ad plus
our negative designation so the patient
presents to their local emergency
department with a four day history of
fever and fatigue and blood work showed
that the patient was neutropenic so due
to this patient's clinical presentation
but also their CMV cyril mismatch that
was determined prior to their
transplantation the whole blood sample
was collected and it was sent to the
local laboratory supporting the hospital
for a CMV viral load test and that
result was reported as detected or
positive at 17,500 copies per milliliter
so the team decides to follow this
result closely and they actually order a
repeat CMV viral load one week later
however it's important to point out that
that repeat test is performed on a
plasma specimen and it's sent to a
regional reference lab and the result
comes back and is reported as ten
thousand international units per ml so
when the provider receives the report of
that second CMV viral load they call the
reference laboratory and they ask the
question why is there been a decline in
the viral load this particular patient
hasn't been started on any antiviral
treatment yet so before we continue with
our case and help to answer that
particular question I'd like to review
some background information on sada
megalo virus or CMV CMV is a member of
the herpes
as we mentioned earlier and its name is
derived from the type of changes it
caused to infected host cells so cyto
means cell and mega means large and as
you can see in the image on the right
hand side of this slide infected cells
are enlarged and the nuclei of infected
cells also become enlarged and give
what's called a characteristic owl's I
inclusion appearance similar to other
herpes viruses CMV has a double-stranded
DNA genome and it obtains its envelope
that surrounds the nucleocapsid from the
host cell membrane as newly formed
variants emerge from the infected host
cell CMV as a worldwide distribution and
the serial prevalence of the virus is
directly proportional to age so the vast
majority of adults in developing nations
an estimated and greater than 90% are
serial positive or show evidence of
being infected again by the time they
reach adulthood importantly CMV
undergoes what's called latency
following acute infection which means
it's not cleared from the host it
actually undergoes latency and basically
hides out in the infected individual and
this plays a significant role in disease
among transplant patients because they
become immune suppressed sometimes
severely immune suppressed following
transplantation and that makes them
highly susceptible to reactivation of
latent virus so due to the high serial
prevalence of the virus and its ability
to undergo latency CMV is one of the
most common complications affecting
transplant recipients although infection
or
activation is often asymptomatic or
subclinical and infected individuals
disease manifestations among the
transplant population may include what's
called CMV syndrome which is often
characterized by a nonspecific febrile
illness that can be associated with
malaise in neutropenia
in addition CMV can cause pneumonitis
hepatitis gastrointestinal disease and
then a variety of diseases associated
with the central nervous system so what
are the laboratory methods that are
available to assist in the diagnosis and
monitoring of CMV infection we've
mentioned serology and syria logic
testing for IgG class antibodies against
CMV is important for screening both the
donor and the recipient
prior to a transplant and this is done
so that we can determine the recipients
risk for developing disease following
their transplant however it's important
to point out that serology has no role
in the diagnosis of active CMV disease
in the post transplant period so after
the transplant is performed
serology is not a recommended approach
to try and determine whether an
individual is having active disease
viral cultures often thought of as a
gold standard approach for diagnosing
viral infections but this method
actually has limited to no clinical
utility in the transplant population
especially when it's performed on
certain sample types such as urine or
blood and that's because CMV like other
herpes viruses can actually be shed and
certain specimen types urine blood being
examples of those in the absence of
clinical disease so in other words
growing CMV from a urine sample lacks
what's called clinical specificity or a
direct association with clinical disease
antigen emia assays that target the
protein PP 65 have been used in the past
to diagnose and monitor CMV and
transplant recipients but it's important
to emphasize that PP 65 antigen emia is
labor intensive so it requires a lot of
effort on the performing laboratory side
it provides only semi quantitative
results and probably most importantly a
lack standardization so that results
from one laboratory can't be directly
compared to those reported from another
lab so because of these limitations
antigen emia assays have been replaced
over the course of the last five to ten
years by quantitative molecular testing
which I'll refer to as viral load assays
and these viral load tests are now
considered to be the method of choice
for diagnosing and monitoring or
assisting in the management of CMV in
the transplant population so with that
background information on the clinical
manifestations of CMV and the diagnostic
tools that we have in our toolbox let's
go back to our case for an update if you
recall we've got a patient who's nine
months out from a lung transplant and he
presents to his emergency department
with a CMV like syndrome and so viral
load testing is performed one at his
local hospital and the result was 17,500
copies per ml on a whole blood but then
ten thousand international units per ml
one week later but that test was
performed on a plasma sample at a
regional reference lab
so although at first it's definitely
understandable that those results may
appear to be suggesting a reduction in
viral load it's critical to emphasize
that those particular values can't be
directly compared and they can't be
compared for several reasons first the
testing was performed on different
sample types so the first one was done
on whole blood and the other performed
on plasma and then the second reason is
that the results are reported in
different units so that first test was
reported in copies per milliliter and
the second was reported in international
units per ml now although there are
several key pearls from this case that I
want to highlight and first CMV nucleic
acid which you might hear referred to as
DNA emia
or the presence of nucleic acid or DNA
and the blood stream is generally
detected earlier and higher values or
amounts when testing is performed on a
whole blood sample in comparison to
another sample type like plasma or serum
and because of this routine testing of
whole blood can actually provide greater
clinical sensitivity so in other words
you may pick up or detect CMV infection
sooner or in a whole blood than in other
sample types like plasma however
detection of CMV in whole blood may not
always correlate with clinical disease
and data currently suggests that testing
plasma may actually provide greater
clinical specificity in other words
detection of CMV and plasma may be more
closely associated with the virus
causing disease in that patient in 2018
guidelines were published on the
diagnosis and management of CMV and the
solid organ transplant population and
some of the key recommendations from
this report are summarized on this slide
one of the first guidelines or
recommendations I wanted to highlight
was that laboratories should use an
assay that's been calibrated against the
World Health Organization's
international standard and that w-h-o
standard allows for results to be
reported in international units or I you
per ml preferably labs should adopt an
assay that's FDA approved for CMV viral
load testing and I've included some
examples of the FDA approved tests which
include the Abbott real-time the Cajun
artists and the Roche Kobus CMV assays
in addition to the guidelines
highlighting the importance of
monitoring patients using the same assay
the guidelines also emphasized the need
to pick one sample type so either whole
blood or plasma and stick to that sample
type throughout the course of the
patients long-term management as we
discussed on the previous slide this is
due to the inherent differences in viral
load that can be observed between whole
blood and plasma and finally the trend
in viral load so how the viral load
changes over time is likely more
important than a single value or one
viral load at one point in time because
it's really difficult or has been up to
date up to this point to establish a
viral load threshold that can be used to
define disease in all patient groups
when monitoring the trend and viral load
it's recommended to perform testing
about every five to seven days and labs
are encouraged to report the integer
and/or
a log transformed value so in other
words if a viral load is determined to
be 1,000 international units per ml the
lab should if they decide to report out
that integer value of 1000 they should
also report out the value as 3 log since
differences of at least one half log are
required to represent a clinically
significant change in the lab we can
actually see differences of between
point two and point 3 log between tests
simply due to inherent biologic or test
variability so if a technologist
pipetted the same sample five times we
can see up to 0.2 or 0.3 log variability
just based on that inherent lab test
variability so we look for at least a
half log to be considered clinically
significant regarding variability and
CMV viral load testing a number of past
studies have assessed the
reproducibility of the fda-approved test
compared to laboratory developed tests
and in a study that was published in
Clinical infectious diseases in 2013 the
investigators sent a panel of contrived
samples to multiple laboratories and
those labs tested the panel members by
an fda-approved system as well as a
laboratory developed tests or tests now
as you can see on the left-hand side of
this slide testing performed by the FDA
approved platform showed pretty tight
precision of results over the analytical
measurement range among the testing
sites now when we compare that to the
precision of results when labs performed
a lab developed test you can see that
the results of the lab developed tests
showed much
us precision with a greater scatter of
the results across the analytical
measurement range and so the results
from this particular study have been
confirmed and supported by other groups
who have shown that use of fda-approved
assays an importantly adoption of assays
that are calibrated against the w-h-o
international standard yield increased
precision and reproducibility so let's
return to our first case and wrap things
up so if you recall we had testing viral
load testing performed at a reference
lab that showed a viral load of ten
thousand international units per ml and
this would be concerning for CMV disease
in the particular patient so the team
just decided to repeat that at the same
reference lab and that was done and it
showed an increase of approximately one
log in comparison to the first test so
that patient was started on gancyclovir
therapy at that point now the CMV viral
load was monitored and it showed a nice
response to therapy over the first four
weeks and actually things seemed pretty
stable through about week ten after the
patient was diagnosed with CMV and
started on therapy but beginning at week
eleven you can see that there was an
appreciable increase in the viral load
over the next two weeks and this would
definitely raise concern for the
emergence of antiviral resistance in
this patient so in general resistance
should be considered if there is
persistent or rising CMV DNA amia during
prolonged antiviral therapy and it's
important that i underscore that CMV
viral loads can actually increase during
the first two weeks after therapies
initiated
so typically transplant teams don't make
significant modifications to the
treatment strategy during that first two
weeks because the viral load may not
show a decline right out of the gate but
if resistance is suspected there are
some lab tools that we can use and the
method of choice currently is sequencing
of certain genes and the CMV genome
including two genes
you'll 97 and you'll 54 and there are
some others that are being investigated
and testing tested for such as UL 56 but
what we look for is specific mutations
in these genes that have been shown to
be associated with antiviral resistance
now resistance mutations are most common
in the gene Newell 97 and when we see
specific mutations in UL 97 they
typically confer resistance to
gancyclovir less commonly we can see
mutations arise in the UL 54 gene and
when that occurs the virus may actually
have cross resistance to multiple drugs
including gancyclovir and phos garnet
and/or Sedova vir now up until recently
the majority of sequencing tests have
been performed using traditional singer
methods however certain labs are
beginning to implement a new type of
technology called next-generation
sequencing and the potential benefits of
next-generation sequencing or NGS assays
is that these tests may be able to
detect resistant viral populations at
levels lower than 20% which is typically
the threshold for singer sequencing and
in addition it
propose that NGS based assays may be
able to better differentiate mixed
populations of virus within a particular
patient so if there is a mixture of
wild-type and resistant virus the NGS
essays may be able to more accurately
differentiate those so to summarize this
portion of the presentation CNB
quantitative viral load testing is
essential in the diagnosis and
management of CMV disease following
transplantation in regards to viral load
testing standardization is key labs are
strongly encouraged to use fda-approved
assays that are calibrated against the
w-h-o standard and perform testing on a
standardized specimen type for a
particular patient so if we're gonna
follow a patient using plasma just use
plasma if you decide to use whole blood
monitor that patient with whole blood
throughout the course of their
management in addition the trend and
viral load is likely more important than
a single result and we look for changes
of at least one half log between results
before we consider the change to be
clinically significant and once a
patient's been started on antiviral
therapy it's recommended to monitor that
patient by a viral load test on a weekly
basis and if you see persistent or
rising viral loads over a prolonged
period of time you can actually assess
for resistance by a sequencing based
method either a singer' sequencing or an
NGS approach okay so let's move on to
discuss another important viral
infection in the transplant population
and we'll do that by moving on to our
second case and in this case we have a
74 year old with a history of primary
sclerosing cholangitis who underwent a
liver transplant and fortunately this
patients
suffered a complication of ischemic
cholangitis that necessitated a second
liver transplant just three weeks later
now things go relatively well for the
first few months after the second
transplant and the patient's seen and
routine follow-up but they have elevated
liver enzymes there is a protocol liver
biopsy performed and that shows a queue
colon gitis the team treats the patient
with a round of antibiotics and the
symptoms seemed to improve now the
patient seems relatively stable over the
next several months but again seen for
routine evaluation again has elevated
liver enzymes now the patient doesn't
describe any recent fever chills but
does at this point complain of some
significant back pain over the last week
show here the patient's current
medications that include an antiviral as
well as their immunosuppressive and
because of these findings and the
patients complained of back pain the
team decides to get an MRI and a PET
scan now this image shows a section of
the MRI and this was read out by the
radiologist as numerous intrahepatic
focal rim enhancing lesions most likely
representing metastasis in addition here
are the results of the PET scan and I
think you can probably appreciate the
concerning findings and the radiologist
commented that there are innumerable
hypermetabolic focal hepatic lesions
scattered throughout the liver
parenchymal so as both the patient's
clinical and radiographic features would
be concerning in this particular case a
number of additional studies were
performed
including viral load testing for CMV and
EBV the CMV viral load was reported as
undetectable but the EBV viral load was
extremely high with a value of over 19
million international units per
milliliter now interestingly the EBV
cero status of the donor and recipient
prior to the second transplant was d
positive or negative so the donor was
determined to be cyril positive for EBV
and this recipient was zero negative and
this would actually represent a high
risk for EBV infection following the
transplant now to confirm the diagnosis
a liver biopsy was performed and showed
evidence of a malignant process and as
you can see on the left-hand side of
this slide the dark blue to purple
staining pattern would suggest a tumor
like process in comparison to the normal
liver tissue that you can see towards
the bottom of that particular section
specific insight to hybridization
studies were also performed on the liver
biopsy tissue and here you can see the
in situ hybridization probes for EBV did
show a specific staining pattern and
this would confirm that this was indeed
an EBV associated limpo a proliferative
disorder so similar to sodom megalo
virus EBV is a member of the herpes
Verde family it possesses a
double-stranded DNA genome the virus
prevalent preferentially infects b-cells
and it has a worldwide distribution with
an extremely high serial prevelance over
90% in both developing and developed
nations acute infection can be
asymptomatic and many individuals
or it can result in a mononucleosis
syndrome but importantly like CMV the
virus undergoes latency following that
initial infection and then can
reactivate in certain scenarios
including profound immune suppression in
the transplant population EBV infection
may result in post transplant
lymphoproliferative disorder which you
might hear referred to as PT LD over 80%
of cases of PT LD occur during the first
year following transplantation and
patients with PTL d may present with a
nonspecific constitutional illness that
resembles an infectious mononucleosis
those patients can experience fever
weight loss fatigue and lymphadenopathy
PT LD can manifest as a multi-system
disease involving multiple organs or it
can be limited to the transplanted
allograft EBP can also be associated
with other types of malignancies
including a variety of lymphomas and
nasopharyngeal carcinoma laboratory
testing for EBV can be accomplished
through a variety of methods serial
logic screening for IgG class antibodies
prior to transplantation is used in
determining a recipients risk for EBV
disease but like we discussed with CMV
EBV serology really plays no role in the
diagnosis of active disease following
the transplant procedure EBV isn't
routinely recovered in most traditional
cell culture lines and because of that
viral culture is not used again
routinely in the diagnosis of EBV
infection
histopathology with in situ
hybridization using specific EBV probes
is required to confirm disease and
quantitative viral load test
has become the method of choice for
monitoring a patient's response to
therapy it's important to point out that
EBV viral loads can vary significantly
among patients and typically we see much
lower viral loads for EBV
in the clinical laboratory in those that
are infected usually in the range of
three to five log as the graph on the
right hand side shows patients with PT L
D caused by epstein-barr virus may show
much higher viral loads even exceeding
six log or a million copies or
international units but a low viral load
doesn't necessarily mean that a patient
won't develop PT L D and likewise if you
see a high viral load in a transplant
patient that doesn't necessarily mean
that that patient is going to develop or
currently has PT LD when specific
testing for EBV is warranted in
transplant patients quantitative viral
load testing is needed to identify
suspect cases and subsequently monitor
the response to therapy and as we
highlighted with CMV standardization of
EBV molecular testing really is key and
labs are encouraged to use an EBV viral
load a say that's calibrated against the
available WH o international standard
which allows the results to be reported
in international units per ml patients
should be monitored using the same
specimen type and plasma is now being
preferred in many settings in cases of
donor positive recipient negative or
deep plus or negative mismatches it's
recommended to test using a viral load
assay either weekly or bi-weekly for the
first 12 months because
remember that the incidence of PT LD is
greatest during that first year post
transplantation and a d+ r- would
represent a higher risk group but in
low-risk individuals such as when the
serial status is determined be d- r-
patients can be tested monthly for the
first year as we discussed on the
previous slide and elevated EBV viral
load doesn't necessarily mean that a
patient has or will develop PT L D so in
order to confirm the diagnosis you need
other studies including imaging so MRI
PET scans but ultimately you need a
tissue biopsy with histopathology and
specific staining for EBV so let's
return to our second case and see how
things turned out
so given the patient's elevated EBV
viral load and concerning findings on
the MRI and PET scans the transplant
team reduced the levels of
immunosuppression and also initiated
weekly rituximab therapy and you can see
in the table that the EBV viral loads
were followed weekly and showed a
significant decrease over the following
month and the virus actually became
undetectable by week five so a very
substantial response to initiation of
therapy in this patient to summarize a
few diagnostic pearls from case number
two quantitative viral load testing is
important a laboratory tool on cases of
EBV associated PT LD but it's important
to remember that high viral loads aren't
diagnostic for this door this disorder
in addition although the majority of
cases of PT LD are associated with EBV
infection there are some cases that have
very low levels or even undetectable EBV
and therefore those cases may be caused
by some other etiology
our third and final case is that of a 33
year old who underwent a kidney
transplant due to uncontrolled diabetes
and the patient does well during their
first 12 months post transplant and then
is seen for a routine follow-up
appointment where the patient has an
elevated serum creatinine level and then
a urinalysis
reveals pyuria and he materia so a
number of microbiology studies are
performed and notably the patient's BK
viral load on a urine sample is reported
as positive at 22,500 copies per ml a
urine cytology is performed at that time
and shows decoy cells similar to those
that you can see in the image in the top
right hand corner of your slide in
addition a kidney biopsy is stained
using an simian virus forty probe or
sv40 and that shows positive staining
that i've circled and read in multiple
fields so this is BK virus which is a
polyomavirus and it's related to simian
virus 40 or sv40 and that's why the SP
40 probe led up on the kidney biopsy BK
virus was named after a patient from
whom the virus was first isolated in the
early 1970s it's an on envelope virus
it's got a double-stranded DNA genome
and primary infection is believed to
occur during childhood through contact
with oral or respiratory secretions now
the majority of individuals become
exposed to this virus and so serial
prevalence studies suggest that between
60 and 80% of adults have been infected
with BK virus
following acute infection which in many
cases is believed to be asymptomatic the
virus then preferentially persists in
the renal epithelium BK virus can be
associated with significant more about
morbidity and mortality and the
transplant population among kidney
transplant recipients the virus can
cause tubular nephritis or urethral
stenosis and in the stem cell transplant
population BK virus is associated with
hemorrhagic or non hemorrhagic cystitis
less commonly it can cause other
illnesses such as meningoencephalitis
retinitis pneumonitis or hepatitis now
unlike testing for CMV and EBV serologic
screening for BK is not routinely
performed prior to transplantation and
also it's important to point out that
viral culture for BK is not commonly
done instead the diagnosis and
management of BK virus and the
transplant population relies on a
combination of histopathology and
quantitative viral load testing so in
regards to viral load testing urine and
plasma are the most common sample types
that are tested with detection of BK
virus and urine being associated with
high sensitivity and a high negative
predictive value so if you get a
negative result from a urine sample that
has a strong correlation that the
patient does not have BK a related
disease unfortunately though detection
of BK in the urine has low clinical
specificity so many transplant patients
will have detectable BK virus in their
urine but not have disease caused by
that virus in contrast to urine
detection of the
and plasma is felt to have much higher
clinical specificity and plasma is
typically used for monitoring patients
after a urine sample is initially
determined to be positive for BK virus
among the kidney transplant population
the current guidelines recommend
screening patients with a quantitative
molecular assay each month for the first
nine months post transplant again urine
can be used to screen patients but if
urine is positive for BK virus then
testing by plasma is recommended for
monitoring over time if a patient
remains negative by the viral load assay
for the first nine months screening can
then be performed every three months
until the patient's two years out from
their transplantation consistently
elevated or rising BK viral load should
be followed up by a kidney biopsy with
specific insight to hybridization
studies although there are no clear
universally applied thresholds to define
BK v disease it has been suggested that
viral loads of at least a thousand
copies and plasma over a time of three
weeks or a single value that's greater
than 10,000 copies should prompt the
team to consider a reduction in immune
suppression but those values really need
to be validated at each Center in the
stem cell transplant population a
diagnosis of BK associated hemorrhagic
cystitis requires a clinical and
laboratory triad and that triad includes
cystitis macro key materia and a BK
viral load in the urine of at least
seven log it's important to highlight
that although high BK viral loads are
associated with an increased risk for BK
associated cystitis more than 80% of all
stem cell transplants
ian's develop high-level BK viral loads
in the urine despite the fact that only
5 to 20% of stem-cell transplant
recipients go on to develop hemorrhagic
cystitis and because of that you need to
have reflux testing the plasma to
increase that clinical specificity of
the results so I want to finish up this
presentation by showing some interesting
data from a publication in 2018 and this
study highlighted that the viruses that
we've discussed often don't act alone in
the transplant population the authors of
the study assessed over 3,700 samples
that had been collected from 540 kidney
transplant recipients and they tested
these samples by viral load assays for
CMV EBV and BK virus the investigators
also collected clinical characteristics
and then data on graph function and each
of the patients and their results showed
that 57 patients are about 10 percent of
their study cohort had combined
detection of both CMV and BK virus and
when that was observed it was associated
with patients who had a significant
impairment and graph function and
overall their data suggested that
combined reactivation of these viruses
was associated with significant graft
impairment and I think underscores that
these viruses and maybe others
can be present and co-infections in the
transplant population and may impact the
graft survival and the outcomes in
different ways in summary we've
discussed the viral infections including
those caused by CMV EBV and BK are
significant causes of morbidity and
mortality in the transplant population
the diagnosis and management of the
infections is often accomplished through
a combination of viral load testing
imaging and histopathology the
implementation of fda-approved assays
for determining CMV viral loads has
increased the precision and
reproducibility of results among testing
centers and finally in the future we
need to work with our partners and
industry to develop fda-approved viral
load test for EBV and BK virus and use
these standardized laboratory tools to
establish a viral load thresholds that
can be used to distinguish asymptomatic
viral shedding from disease in the
transplant population I'd encourage you
to review the publications that I've
included on the next two slides and
these are excellent resources for
additional information on the topic and
I'd also like to thank doctors Angie
Caliendo and Bobby prett for their
assistance with the images that I
included in cases number two and three
so with that we'll finish up this
discussion on viral infections in the
transplant population and I'd be happy
to address any questions you might have
thanks again for joining me
thank you got to Banneker for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
onions on how to submit questions simply
type them into the drop down box located
on the far left of your presentation
window labeled ask a question and click
on the send button after been occur will
answer as many questions as time permits
ok our first question is why is there no
established viral load threshold for
distinguishing disease from transient
viral shedding
this is a really good question an
important one I think that the the main
reason is that there are a lot of
different types of patients especially
patients that are on varying levels of
immunosuppressive drugs and because of
that it's really difficult for us to
establish that a certain viral load will
apply across the board in all patients
as an indicator of disease versus this
is just transient viral shedding as an
example you may have a stem cell
transplant patient who is on high levels
of an immunosuppressive drug and a CMV
viral load and a patient like that of a
thousand international units may be
significant or as another type of
transplant patient who is less immune
suppressed that same viral load value
may not represent clinically significant
disease so the first step I think we
have to take is getting standardized
testing formats and being able to
compare results across all testing
laboratories the second is we need large
multi-site studies looking at varying
patient populations and we're probably
not going to get to the point where we
have a clearly defined threshold in all
patient scenarios but probably the goal
should be looking for more of a tiered
approach of if viral loads fall in a
certain range that patient may be at low
to moderate risk if a viral load is
exceeding a different tier or range
there a higher risk
that's probably what we should be
shooting for at least in the near term
very good question
great thank you all right your next
question does infection of one
transplant virus predispose or prevent
other transmitted virus infections
so as we talked about during the
presentation many of the primary causes
of viral infection and disease and our
transplant population are herpes viruses
and herpes viruses can cause both acute
and reactivated infection and once a
person is infected with those viruses
they undergo latency and depending on
factors such as I mean a suppression age
can reactivate and cause a subsequent
disease so exposure to them
unfortunately doesn't yield a protective
response although patients that have
pre-existing infection for example if
prior to transplantation the serial
status is determined to be a donor
positive and recipient positive that
individual will have some antibody
response that may prevent a more severe
disease or even disease from occurring
so there's some level of protection but
it doesn't necessarily mean that the
individual won't succumb to infection or
reactivation of the disease so that's
the real challenge with these transplant
associated viruses is that we're not
necessarily protected long term if we
are infected
all right thank you your next question
is how frequently if at all the detail
related diseases occur in recipients of
solid organs have other than kidney
yeah very good question so for sure
because of where BK virus preferentially
persists following acute infection being
in the renal epithelium the the most
common Association of BK virus disease
is with the the kidney transplant
population but we can't see it and other
types of solid organ transplants and
then probably the other than kidneys
that the other class of transplant
patients where we see it very frequently
is in our stem cell transplant
population so it's not completely unique
to the kidney transplant population but
that is a primary group that we're
concerned about with that particular
virus
right thank you I'll write your next
question which next generation
sequencing technology do you think has
the most potential to help the diagnosis
and management of these transplant
viruses
so which NGS technology it's a
relatively new type of technology there
are a number of reference and research
laboratories that have brought up in
Jason G s based technology and there
were actually some commercial companies
who are in the process of developing NGS
based technologies as well there haven't
been large studies comparing available
options yet so I don't think we're able
to say this particular next-gen
sequencing platform provides more
accurate or more sensitive results
compared to another I think those
studies are needed and it will be very
important I think the data that I've
seen show pretty comparable results of
the available ingest platforms and
importantly the studies have looked at
the NGS methods compared to Sanger
sequencing and there appears to be some
improved sensitivity for picking up low
levels of resistant viral populations
and being able to tease apart of
different populations of virus because
it may be important for us to determine
early on if there are 5 to 10 or 15% of
the entire population that Harbor those
resistant mutations because if we treat
them with a certain drug that will wipe
out the wild-type population and allow
the resistant population to to emerge so
it's definitely an interesting area but
I would say stay tuned over the next
several years because a lot more data
will be generated in that area
great thank you okay your next question
what are the complications of abnormal
DNA in the bloodstream
so the complications of viral DNA in the
bloodstream that's that's a tough one to
answer I would say again that when we
monitor for viral infections in the
transplant population that we can
sometimes see elevated viral loads for
CMV EBV BK even other viruses like add
no virus in the blood that those results
may not be associated with clinical
disease because many of these viruses
can be shed transiently again because
these patients are mu and suppressed at
low levels and so I think that's really
the main complication for testing
laboratories and for providers who are
ordering these tests is being able to
interpret what those results mean and
that's why we go back to that need or
that requirement to monitor the viral
load in the blood or the plasma over
time and so we're looking for increases
or decreases over time to help us know
whether that patient is developing
disease or responding to treatment do
hiv-positive transplant recipients have
a higher incidence of reactivation HIV
CMV EBV or BK oh good question
so do patients that are infected with
HIV have a higher incidence of
reactivating these transplant associated
viruses and I think the data have shown
that that population because they are
more inherently immune suppressed that
we do see differences in the infection
rate associated with transplant viruses
so I think the answer is is yes we see
differences in the HIV population but
I'm not a hundred percent as familiar
with all the studies in that area
so I wouldn't be able to give definitive
numbers but I think there are
differences between the non HIV and the
HIV infected population
thank you dr. beniker I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor Abbott molecular for
today's educational webcast laberd's
will alert you via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed is live event until
next time the five